Speaker 1: Let's go next to Bob
from Colorado. Bob, welcome.
Speaker 3: Hey, Dave, thanks for taking my call.
Speaker 1: Pleasure.
Speaker 3: So just about like everybody else,
I'm going to ask about the abortion thing.
Okay. Do you think this could maybe be. Well, let
me let me let me tell you where I'm coming from.
Okay. So I know you mentioned a couple of
times that you think maybe many Republicans
don't want to ban abortion or overturn Roe v Wade
because it's such an important fund raising issue.
Yes. Do you think this could be. With everything
going on with Roe v Wade could be like a long term
loss for them because they lose such
an important political wedge issue.
Speaker 1: Right. So I think it is possible
that in the long term, it will give them it
will take away a tool for the right to raise
money. But remember that in the short run,
just about every blue state and many red states
still allow abortion. So for the next however many
years, they'll just shift to saying, okay, we got
what we needed at the Supreme Court. Now we have
to go state by state to ban abortion. So they'll
just move the goal. So I think they'll have plenty
of cannon fodder or no, I guess I would be the
right term that they'll have plenty of gunpowder
for many years at this point.
Speaker 3: Okay. And do you do you
think it'll become kind of a rallying issue for
the left, maybe get people more motivated to vote?
Speaker 1: That's my hope. And I mentioned this
on Monday. My hope is that absolutely. Or Tuesday.
My hope is that, yes, if there's anything that
can save the midterms, maybe it will be this.
Speaker 3: And kind of because I know one of the
issues with the left is we have really low turnout
and kind of there's kind of a belief
among many people that voting doesn't
matter. Everybody's the same.
Speaker 1: All that matters,
huh? I mean, let's think back to 2016 now.
Speaker 3: Exactly. So hopefully this will
be it's kind of like the fire and everybody
make everybody wake up and realize, holy crap.
Speaker 1: That's my hope. I mean, listen,
this is a disaster, but if there is to be any
silver lining, that would potentially be it. And
we'll know within a few months if that happens.
Speaker 3: All righty. Thank
you for taking my call, David.
Speaker 1: Thank you for the call. There
is Bob, a very, very important issue.